romanian designer you wanna chela coo at
a fitting for her debut fashion show in
berlin shalako calls her collection
hunters and it's 25 designs reflect the
interaction between hunter and prey the
cornerstone of this collection was laid
a year ago when chilaka won the designer
for tomorrow fries at Berlin Fashion
Week actually is one year and five days
yes yeah I remember of course it was my
first big fitting and it was hectic
because we kept with switching models I
mean it's the same now but this more
relaxed because I already have the
experience so I'm more relaxed one year
ago chilaka was one of five finalists
for the designer for tomorrow award
chosen from a pool of 350 applicants
British fashion designer Stella
McCartney was the competition's patron
and in the end mccartney and the panel
of fashion experts chose chilaka and her
paradox collection as the winner
she just really sort of had a great
point of view and a lovely silhouette
quite architectural quite statement but
at the same time quite wearable and I
think that's kind of what I'm looking
for in these kind of things somebody
that's really new and the way they
approach design but also at the same
time somebody that you you feel you want
to wear the award provided chilaka with
financial support and assistance in
establishing her own label she's now
opened her own studio in the Romanian
capital Bucharest shalako accompanied
McCartney and her team when they put on
a show at paris fashion week and she
visited the british designer at her
studio in london it wasn't any more
advice regarding design which she knows
best because I think that she she thinks
that I'm prepared already so it was more
of a industry import you know how
business works you know that's why I
visited her studio because I opened my
studio so you know I wanted to know
what's the level of how many people are
they you know how they work how do they
manage everything so that was more
important designer for tomorrow winners
also get the chance to stage their own
show at Berlin Fashion Week the model is
the PR the health backstage they've all
been organized for you wanna chill aku
the young designer hopes to take the
fashion world by storm from her
headquarters in Bucharest she plans to
produce her collection in Romania as
well it's her way of supporting her
country's economy and ensuring good
quality
these are moment its lungs up in fact
like this moment in time is slow
compared to what's coming next meaning
that things are getting quicker and more
global lubali not under the matter
markets are opening up is being thank
you so I think this point of view is the
right one 50 games rider these days
designers can stay where they are and
still communicate with the whole world
community on and like the bad view maybe
at some stage will no longer need venues
like Fashion Week but find completely
different platforms like Megan's under
the platform cloud so people should
start off where they feel most
comfortable sign big unsung soldier
european clothing store chain peak and
cloppenburg Dusseldorf has been
sponsoring the designer for tomorrow
competition since 2009 the patron of
this year's competition is the American
designer Tommy Hilfiger chilaka show
kicks off the finale
and there's still time for her to enjoy
the attention and support that's on
offer before she has to stand on her own
two feet there has been a lot of
emotions for me I never had so many
emotions in my life because of the you
know weenie and the preparations before
and now you know again with the show
again the same feelings but I was grown
up really good so now I have the power
to be on my own I guess after the show
you wanna chill aku is ready to launch
her career as an independent designer
she's no longer a designer for tomorrow
she's creating fashions for today